I would you think back to last lesson
and we went right down to the buzzer
slightly what's up and we looked
particularly and what happens when you
don't just take any series but you take
a tape remember we had the story who was
the main character in the story it was
house and his lazy teacher right and he
determined okay if I have this a plea
okay it is relatively easy to work out
what is going on his method was to pair
up the person or lost the second and the
second last and so on each of those
pairs if you recall adds up to noon
cover looked one hundred and a hundred
and one and how many such pairs are
there there are fifty good so we
established this right now what we did
was we took it more specifically to AP's
we said that you can think about this in
a couple of ways number one somebody
made we had two definitions for or two
formulas if you like both of them were
based on this pairing idea so the Sun
the partial song up to the nth term
started with and on to that's how many
pairs you've got in the series and
what's there in the brackets what which
way - gasps - it yeah just the first
term and the last term which
infuriatingly is a plus element okay now
this is perfect if what you got is start
here and there okay so if you have
handed to you the last term you don't
need to appeals it you don't even need
to know what the common difference is
right you just need to work out how many
terms there are and as you first knew us
done okay but of course and we know that
ApS have this structure and we sometimes
go what the common difference is we can
take advantage of that
so if instead of knowing what the last
term is right we substitute in what the
last term is equal to mainly turn in to
your van which is remember it's a start
to be first class and how many lights
the common difference n minus 1 right
and that's where we ended up I believe
we wrote this okay why there 2 a's in
there because you've got the actual
first term right and then you've got the
part of the first term that is lumped in
with the last time okay so that's why
there's this you wait yeah so does that
mean for milk yup you you sort of assume
in some way that there is a when we are
it's a good question what we are talking
about these things here right and
there's a there's an actual value for em
right we'll look at what happens with it
is it the value for n that's interesting
in its own right but here it's a partial
sum we're defining these as partial sums
which by definition means they're fine
oh okay so - yes and in fact both of
them both forms kind of assume there's a
last term there's an inner term and
that's where you stop okay so just to
make sure you got this in your head
right when do we use this we use this
one but we know it that first time last
turns up
alternatively is it slightly different
piece of information you would have in
order to work out this frizzes you could
craft a question how would you phrase a
question like this without knowing what
the last time was you might say well
yeah you don't have enjoy yeah okay good
so if you know how many terms there are
and then what they differ by so for
instance can you add up for me the first
100 even terms okay now I know it's
trivially easy to work out what the
hundred even time is okay even though
but the last one is going to be that's
not too difficult bless you but I don't
need to know what the last term is I
know what the common difference is
namely to I know the first term is and I
can go ahead and do it
okay so I use this instead when I learn
when the first term
there's my a in there right common
difference and what's the last piece of
information that I need look at the
corner
yeah how many times there are a number
of terms he's learning
for what it's worth I actually didn't
write it but you need to know the number
of terms for the first method to because
you need to know how many pairs you've
got that make sense